just over five years ago then president
barack obama changed the name of the
tallest peak in north america
the summit known as mount mckinley
became denali once again
an original native alaskan name with
deep cultural significance
today as our nation russell's with the
past and questions about those we've
chosen to honor another mountain
may be in line for a new name as well
from colorado
barry peterson has the story
the majesty of mount heavens as captured
by preeminent colorado photographer
john fielder named for john evans an
1800s
colorado territorial governor some say
the naming honors the winning of the
west can you see it from here
yeah right there front and center right
over those trees
location that most anybody can see in
the denver metro area
ernest house jr is a member of the ute
mountain ute tribe and former
executive director of the colorado
commission of indian affairs
and the great grandson of jackhaus
the last hereditary chief of the ute
mountaineer
tribe to house the name evans means
this his connection with the sand creek
massacre of
november 29 1864 will forever go down in
history
on a mark on his status as somebody who
has been a historical figure for the
state of colorado he didn't participate
in the massacre
he had a level of culpability evans
issued a proclamation saying
kill and destroy all hostile indians so
tribes
surrendered to the government for
protection and some
settled at sand creek but in an early
morning attack
a group of the u.s cavalry slaughtered
mostly elderly men
women and children today it's a national
historic site now the u.s board of
geographic names is considering
changing the name of mount evans along
with other
colorado sites negro creek [ __ ]
gulch
[ __ ] mountain [ __ ] is a derogatory
word
made up by non-native americans seen as
both racist
and a sexual slur patty limerick is
faculty director of the center
of the american west at the university
of colorado boulder
and a member of the state advisory group
on the name
changes do you take into account that
maybe it's difficult for people to use
that particular name
like i don't want to call something
[ __ ] it's an exceedingly pejorative
term
right i mean i think for a certain
percentage of the population saying it
would be
a uncomfortable moment for 50 years
randy wheelock has hiked biked and
camped on mount evans
he is also in the county commission
where mount evans is located
and while he supports the name change a
constituent
does not and he said to me that i grew
up here and it's the only name that i've
ever known that by
and that means a lot to me and i don't
know why we had to change it how do you
recognize the the people who say but no
this is my growing up this is my
heritage we
really have to listen to that and those
people are being sincere as well
but there's something deeper going on
here statues
symbolizing america's slavery era
toppled
protest over black people who have been
killed and
calls to face centuries of systemic
racism
and changing central names of places
named mostly for white men
as a way to broaden our history well we
understand
that the legacy of white supremacy
around indigenous and native american
people
the removal of native people from their
lands
these were of course egregious events
erica dunbar is a professor of history
at rutgers university
our question to her why now
we're reckoning with this very real
issue around social justice around
representation but it spilled over
into into the public space into this
public sphere of
renaming um peaks or mountains or
forests or parks
this conversation about who we want
to be as americans tell me what you're
going to feel when you look at that
mountain
and it's got an indian name you know i
think the the first thing
i'm going to think about is
those tribal elders that i spoke with
with the shine arapaho tribes
that were sobbing that took an
opportunity to open up
about what the impact sand creek had on
them
but also those tribes that were forcibly
removed from our beautiful state
that continue to call colorado home that
would love for an opportunity to go back
to a mountain take their family and say
this used to be ours and it's still
being recognized we're being
acknowledged
what's in a name it turns out
everything for cbs this morning
saturday barry peterson denver
the question yeah the question that
shakespeare asked what's in the name
[ __ ] valley
in lake tahoe they are changing their
name from [ __ ]
yeah owning it owning all of it that's
who we are as americans and we've got to
own the
the good and the bad no matter what the
intent was in the beginning